hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to little nightmares
now we just escaped from the prison
which it only seemed like it was a
prison for little kids
and why is music starting up right now
and why is this their case so huge and
also this is a staircase from the
opening menu of the game
oh hello now hi
I'm gonna go up here first now I'm going
to risk falling down into the chasm
below because this want to do that
recently but oh hi Oh what do we have
here sorry okay what am I looking at
it's got a pile of dead bodies for all I
know it could be a pile of dead bodies
no didn't make it there here Hulu now
can't do it bad
paving up here then I really don't know
what all the Easter eggs are for and
that's what I can only assume are they
like small little things that I'm like
the knickknacks and the dolls I don't
know what I'm supposed to be doing with
them except casting them and I hi hello
why did that move is there something in
there hello
okay I'm assume it's nothing and why is
everything stretched upwards does the
make an expense and I think I need this
to flip that switch over there maybe I
can take that jug of booze drink my
sorrows away Oh secret hatch okay hmm
ah okay I have a funny feeling we're
either underwater or we are currently oh
boy we're currently oh I guess I can do
that okay good good for me huh
we're either underwater or were on a
boat I'm kind of leaning towards a boat
right now because it's very swing swung
you huh
no no I meant to grab the light but I
don't know why I thought I could do that
Oh oh hi I didn't think I can open this
in houma God that is a painting on the
wall I'm not going to say if it's good
or bad just in case I'm insulting
someone but it's it's definitely a
painting so the key goes over there so
that's important to remember
I think Oh perché uncles and as so long
as I'm able to get up here again why why
did that happen what is with the room
please okay but either way we're not
going to try to jump on the light like a
stupid idiot and then we're gonna
actually go the way it wants me to go
which is over here yeah then down here
fill and then grab the key hello and
then we're good to go I think anyway
boink
grab it grab it grab it don't you not
grab it why oh dude just chuck it off
the way don't be so rude alright so
we're going to put this in the key or
the lock I guess the key goes in the
lock and I know what words to say when
I'm supposed to say them and ha Boesky
ha all right
and then we grab that and then I guess
we just shove it in there for whatever
reason is giant a skeet I don't know if
I need this but I can pick it up take it
with me I guess just to hide my trail
huh okay never mind then
just go set it down Jeff wait there's
something up there hello no I can't get
up there but it looked like there might
have been oh yeah
that's a nice monkey oh good okay I
don't know what I'm supposed to do about
that but maybe do I need this monkey for
something else can I drag this over
there maybe I know it wants me to hit
this button but I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to do need someone bigger
and stronger to be able to do this for
me all right whatever I'm gonna take
this with me because apparently maybe
I'll need this I don't know why I'd need
this I just just suspecting that I might
need this
Hey okay Oh No oh don't do that don't do
that just don't do that
whoa oh oh I can throw real good because
of this oh come on
don't throw it like that throw it harder
throw it harder ah
boo-ki uh-huh Oh for some reason I
thought that was gonna go wham right on
top of my head let's take you with me
you're useful so you got to hold the
button down don't make it throw longer
which is good I suppose and I'm supposed
to do this oh yeah ha ha
boo-ki nailed it nailed and I'm gonna
crawl in here because I think there's
going to be some coming after me you
never know when there's going to be
something else coming in the elevator
wants to kill me very very very dead
maybe eat me up I don't know
because I don't know why they keep
people in cages why would they keep
little children such as me in cages or
maybe not even me
maybe I'm vermin compared to all of
these giants maybe I'm just
itty-bitty worthless vermin to be
stepped upon I know not how could I know
maybe I'm a fully grown huh wha what
happening
wait yeah you see some here okay daddy
if it was gonna blast me or suck me in
and chop me up all right yeah I monkey
oh god what is going on I can't be
starving already I just had a bite to
eat I mean I think there's just
something wrong with me unless I
absolutely just need food oh no oh no oh
no no no I'm a happy on a have to eat
that rat aren't I uh-huh
Oh No I'm gonna have to eat that rat oh
oh oh no I see a rat hanging there right
down there oh no I'm not doing so good
thing I brought this monkey with me oh
no oh oh oh oh good I don't have to eat
the rat the giganto and rats
but there's meat in here and this is a
trap there's very clearly a trap I'm
just gonna you know I'll just get it you
know grab this just for company in this
cage here I'm gonna make sure that I'm
not alone here no come on now you can
get it you can get in there yes yes
you're gonna join me in here in this
trap
I can I can I eat this my goody goody
there we go
nope nope there we go nom nom nom oh you
wouldn't judge me
would you mandoline the monkey oh okay I
knew it was a trap I knew is good old
Mildred the monkey is gonna keep me
company in here all weird Mildred go
word Mantlo go oh god oh why why are you
doing this why admit the thing you do oh
why which is why I'm as I before of a
poor child maybe Oh like why would they
keep me in cases huh oh wow
ow ow ow ow okay I need to go this way
huh ow yeah
well [ __ ] dude he probably heard that
but maybe I can get one of these other
guys out of here
maybe there's something over here oh oh
very nice
oh come with me little one I'm not going
to help you or nothing you say Huddle's
in a heap I guess you're still alive I
think what all hope has been lost long
ago okay here we go hello hello there we
go and then ha all right
and with my let that go okay so that's
problem so I need something to be able
to keep that open that's probably gonna
be over here oh good is that well [ __ ]
didn't mean to do that okay Oh
oh that's handy I can carry this lantern
with me have I always been able to do
that oh that doesn't help anybody at all
alrighty then
well I'm gonna do my best here I don't
know why I did this here but okay can't
carry that with me maybe I'm just gonna
toss this into the abyss is that a good
idea or a bad idea
oh my god it's bad but here we go anyway
well see ya see ya buddy glad I did that
now it's gonna bode well when it
explodes all the methane down in the
bottom here okay so what I got to do is
I got to find a way can I use any of
these no okay so I got to find either a
way to climb up these things
maybe there's something at the top that
could help me or or oh oh
[Music]
is it climb up oh nevermind that was all
[ __ ] alright fine then come with me
and you'll see a world of pure
imagination but oh I can swing swung and
then using my momentum when I let go
I'll be flung into the elevator and then
I won't have to worry
ah I already know what's up man I
already know what's up you think I don't
know what is up my cranky grill ah ah ha
ha ha Shantay there's a way to go what's
going on where am I now
oh ok I pull on this pipe no oh can I
pull on these No oh oh well it seems
awfully problematic I'm in a room with
nothing inside of it I can't climb on
this like oh I can climb on this
apparently Oh
oh good man I am just an agile little
[ __ ] or nice crickety creaky no one's
going to notice this sneekybeeky greedy
greedy can i light that I bet I can is
that a guillotine why what why
why is there getting hurt I like that
very much
Oh God okay hmm that's something to
worry about oh hi oh don't you frickin
dare all right here we go Oh what are
you doing what are you doing
you didn't see nothing oh no Nikki P oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh no oh no I didn't do something
right oh no um I've been grabbed oh I
guess it didn't kill me when okay
alrighty then I don't know what to make
of that but I saw the crank that I need
to put in the crew then I'll know what
to do but maybe if I sneak maybe if I'm
old so Jim what are you doing when in
the world are you doing no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
oh it's blind oh my god it doesn't
matter if I'm quiet anyway it blind oh
my god that's crazy so if I put that in
there whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
you oh it's sniffing the smells
yeah ah [ __ ] it sniffing the smells so
it can only smell it's blind and it can
hear I guess so if I keep Sankey things
around me or I lead it to stanky things
then maybe just maybe I can misguide it
and that'll help me huh but then they're
just put on meat hooks like that I mean
that's messed up man that's messed up
how do you smell that do I smell like
fresh meat or something I don't know
what that's about but apparently this
has got to go in the thing grab it grab
it
any day now nope okay well you can just
make a few passes of errors okay you
could drop it too that's also an option
I don't know why he's not going for me
now oh well what is that my cranky crew
I am here what can you do about it oh I
can't believe that worked
okay I'm gonna go before he grabs me
because I think you can still grab me
from up there with his long
[Music]
no don't like that don't like that at
all
like that at all I don't know why he
didn't go for me that time but I think I
lucked out there and I didn't have to do
the thing that I was supposed to do
which is bad because then I didn't learn
how to do the thing that I was supposed
to do I think it was something about the
stanky shoes which I believe are the
shoes of the children that he's all my
god oh no oh my god holy [ __ ] this is
like this is like the the Holocaust
Museum exhibit just the shoes from the
concentration camps just dip the shoes
and what that represents that's worth Oh
what is that even more horrifying on
that thing what me the [ __ ] hell
there's a shoe monster really there's a
shoe monster oh dang why won't you get
up what I tell you to get up I'm telling
you what they know you just got it do it
you just gotta do it I swear to you I'm
telling you what to do okay come on okay
so I I think jumping in this is a
fruitless venture so I'm just gonna try
to grab there we it's just grab you just
got to grab it
ha but it will be okay that's what it is
and that's what I'll do
oh yes my crankiest crew
oh yeah jumping is a fruitless venture
jumping is a fruitless venture okay oh
there we go you freak off you stupid
creepy shoe monster he's my one now oh
I'm back where I am I was before I got
captured I recognized the rat bear
alright let's carry on I guess bye okay
hi
alrighty then I'm gonna keep going oh no
why do you need to be here and why do
you need to do that you creepy bastard
no no no no no no no no no it'll never
find me in here he'll never find me oh
he's gonna find me hi guys I'm around
stinky shoes man okay oh okay alright
then
yeah not there you big dumb idiot oh oh
not there I know yeah oh yeah that's
more like it yeah
yeah pretty much yeah I'm pretty much
exactly there yes oh god stop moving
your face like that you weirdo it's like
it's fake
oh go get it go get it go get him oh
it's like its face dude yeesh it's like
his face is peeled down from the top of
his head just down around his eyes
that's that's really weird why if that
is true either he's wearing a mask or
his face peeled down around his face
oh hello friend Oh Barry Manilow the
monkey why did that move why
what I don't like that I don't like that
I don't put you back in the toy box I
guess no that didn't work okay Oh Mary
now I left mr. Mumba Lou I left mr.
Magoo the monkey up there you can't
smell me down here can you god you have
your weird short stumpy legs did you
suck all the length from your legs and
I'm guessing dong area and insert it in
of your hand
oh it's Mildred oh hi Michael how you
doing Oh Matthew the mighty Matthew up
there too there's tons of them to think
I was giving him a whole bunch of names
because they're not unique is it doing
yes that is a spoon mister Salad Fingers
congratulations you found a spoon and
where am I going
ah so we look his face is just like
peeled down why uh it's so gross oh my
god it's another porcelain doll why why
are these down here and why oh oh I was
supposed to break those with something
in that well idea I don't know I didn't
know that was what I was supposed to do
all right then I broke that so good
maybe I guess
all right well he's gone so uh okay um
mom blow could you uh help me out here I
don't work so I don't know I'm supposed
to do
oh boy ah oh I see hmm so I think I was
supposed to climb back up here when he's
in the other room and maybe oh no I'm
just about to be here oh no no no no no
no you missed me huh ah dummy you missed
me
just stupid idiot just stupid dumb no no
I wasn't making them crack your neck
like that I think I know what I need to
do I need to throw one of the monkeys
down and it's gonna make a lot of noises
ah and then he's going to be distorted
I said nurses and then he's not gonna
know where I am because he's only got
smell his good old sniffer Snooper and
he's got his ear hearers as long as he
knows about those I'm gonna be just fine
so I need to take this take take this oh
lucky yeah yeah yeah yeah go for that
why don't you go go buddy go go go
go over there oh that's good yeah 99
and then Oh No are you how did he kiss
me then all right I got to figure this
out because again I got through the
other place with a whole lot of luck
maybe I should just throw the monkey and
then get the buggy out of there because
it's obviously making more noise than I
am so it might be a better idea yes so
there is carpet and I think that is
fundamentally important so I gotta stay
on a carpet you can hear
[Music]
yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's it that's it you near nothing
good in here nothing oh that is it okay
I got this I got this
and I push this it's gonna pause - out
of the way I was hoping it was gonna
fall and get bigger crash but no such
luck it's mine today okay that's good
okay so it gets calm carpets and cool
headedness that's going to win the day
also crack cocaine lots of that get the
five C's in there
cool calm bullheadedness crack cocaine
dot five season oh did you get there is
there more than one of you okay stay on
the carpets
that's carpet there's cool carpet calm
cool cool carpet gone carpet cool
headedness crack cocaine
squeaks Quang squeaks Kwong's creaks
clunk why are there so many nooses on
all these clocks by the way is that
supposed to be symbolism here is there
something else going on
[Music]
well that was quiet glad I did that I'm
gonna just be over here now don't worry
about it dude don't worry about it man
dude don't worry about him a dude I
thought I told you to not worry about
him adieu alrighty then I'm assuming
that it's all fine
[Music]
maybe it's fine seems like it might be
fine oh okay yeah Oh
ah that's when I can move I get it okay
I get it I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it I get it thank you yeah
maybe you shouldn't be in this room you
a douche maybe you should get the paws
out of it
let's go there go breathe stay calm and
on the carpets almond on the carpet calm
and on the car grab me if you grab me
grab me growing
why would you move sliding on the
country ah think it need to run now cool
calm collected and carpets oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy you don't know where I am
you do is going up oh well flip through
here maybe come on let throw there we go
whoa a books what am I supposed to do
about these books am I supposed to climb
up them oh can almost see my eyes from
here I think I see my hair alrighty then
yep ok this is working as it's
definitely dangerous why why is that a
thing can I open this no really I can't
climb these cuttlebug shelves more than
just learning oh can I make it over that
lip usek
ok alright gonna like this and then jump
like a boss blank blank
yeah yeah that's good oh hi here we go
hey uh I just feel so weird
everything about this entire world is so
distorted oh hi how do you move around
how did this any of this make sense to
you you're blind
oh I don't understand
yeah I need to find another cranky
yanker so wherever there may be a cranky
anchor that's where I'm gonna go he's
patrolling oh boy can I climb up this
yes I can indeed okay up this I see
another candle to light down there but I
don't know if it's going to do me any
good just going to assume everything is
hunky-dory all right so I need to knock
these down maybe grab that oh yeah
oh yeah flap you like that you like that
and breaking all your [ __ ] justice
vengeance are you being a dick that's
not what I meant to do no no no yeah how
do you like them ah Rick my dick okay
all right okay how's the longer jump
than I want it to be jump
haha didn't make a peep now did wait now
this is how it's supposed to be you dude
alright finally making our way downtown
walking fast moving passing on homebound
oh I'm in a moment okay so I got to go
all the way back don't I that's gonna be
a problem
okay can you can you
come on in here we know how this is
going to work
ah weird how that TV just magically
turned on huh no no no no no no no no no
no how did you know what okay come on
you know faster please Oh God don't get
in my way oh my god
all right okay those way too close I
thought I was done for
bibbidi-bobbidi bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo screw you put that
in there with that in there I don't
think I have time for this but here we
go apparently
can you no no where did he go you
disappear to no another dimension
apparently or he went invisible it's
also could be an OPS plate alrighty then
good point
raluchi all right okay good Flutie all
right we made it where are we now where
is this I don't like this like this here
we go barely maybe I shouldn't be on
this side of this thing but I'm gonna
yeah I think I need to be on the other
side there's got to be a handle on the
other side see because that steam that
seam looks bad deadly almost probably
going to kill me out and oh yeah that's
nice can you jump there you go no no no
no no
okay I'm gonna take you with me because
I'm pretty sure I still need you I
probably could have jumped over the
other way I didn't even need to do that
I could have jumped over the gap huh oh
I did need it I did I did need it I'm a
smarty I'm a smarty oh there we go
whoa Oh screw you okay I see how you be
and again where are we and who built
this place that's an even more important
question than where are we
no probably not but it's also a very
important question who built this place
what kind of engineering principles did
they use what kind of standards do they
do any standards its anything here by
protocol I think not
I'm just going to go a little bit
further here and figure out what's what
here okay I guess you're here maybe I
slipped through no okay bye
ow well alright then I guess that's the
end for me thank you for that
I had no warning and then death
approached faster than I could react so
I'm gonna end this episode here I my
last time but I am loving this game so
far it's such a weird mystery it's such
a weird game I like period but it's such
an interesting mystery of why and I like
it I like the question why because it's
the universe that is here and obviously
every character is just there but why is
it all happening why but either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you everybody so much for letting
me know how this game is in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]